>> Hi, good afternoon.
We are from Bempu Health.
We are a social enterprise
based out of Bangalore.
We make health interventions in
the neonatal and maternal
health care space.
This is our first product.
This is a hypothermia bracelet
for newborn babies,
which we have
managed to deploy to
various states in India and some
countries with the help
of Gates Foundation,
USAID, and Saving Lives of Birth.
With UNICEF. We reached Zimbabwe,
Benin, and Papua New Guinea.
So, while we were
working on our bracelet,
we also identified
various other needs.
So we have a portfolio
of products.
Today, we'll be focusing
on the Care Cradle.
So, the Care Cradle is
a hybrid product service,
which monitors babies,
high-risk babies
at home after they
get discharged from
the neonatal ICU.
This is usually in
low resource settings.
So, just to give
you some context,
there are 750,000 newborns
who die each year in India.
Critical neonates, especially
in low resource settings,
are discharged early from
their facilities because
of the lack of beds,
available beds.
The high-risk period
is thus spent
in uneducated and
geographically isolated homes.
So, again, because the
parents are not well-aware,
they are not usually taken to
the facility if the parents
are unable to identify
symptoms that could indicate
eventual sepsis mortality
and other things.
So, they develop illness at home,
and this could lead to, yes.
So, what we did was
through this cradle,
we collect clinical data.
This is through a smartphone,
which is on top of the cradle.
We collect videos
four times a day.
We ask the parents to record
a two and half minute video with
the press of a button,
four times a day.
We also have
a vital sign monitor,
which is placed on
the baby, which collects
the heart rate and the SPO2.
Nurses call the parents for
an audio account for
information about feeding,
stool urine outputs, etc.
All of that information
is collected on
our dashboard to make a
comprehensive assessment
about the baby's health.
So, now we have a team of
clinicians on the back-end who
review these symptoms
for the duration signs.
Then they alert the family,
or the health worker in
the area is alerted.
So, this is how the system works.
I will talk to you
about the data.
>> So, using a prototype,
which looks like this,
we've tried this program out.
We've piloted it in Karnataka
in Shimoga District,
in Telangana, and in
Bangalore as well.
So, we have used cases from
rural and urban India and
we've seen a lot
of positive value.
So, we've tried this
with about 100 babies,
and in those 100 babies,
we've detected five cases
of readmission.
So, this includes readmission
to tertiary care,
due to illnesses like jaundice,
sepsis, respiratory
distress, etc.
Even illnesses that don't
require readmission,
but just a revisit
to the facility,
can be diagnosed
through signs like
skin color or dropping
the feeding pattern of the baby.
Any sign of dehydration,
any sign of high
respiratory rate,
or chest indrawing, etc.
So, we see that there
is positive value,
but it's difficult to scale
this program because
of certain challenges.
So, one major challenge is
that we require
skilled human resource.
Currently, the clinical team
consists of nurses
and neonatologists,
with significant experience
in neonatal care.
So, the first round of
assessment is done by nurses,
and if there's something
that is deemed to
be wrong with
the health of the baby,
this is escalated to
a neonatologists.
So, each packet of
data would need
at least 15 minutes from
a nurse to be reviewed.
So, effectively, one nurse
on a working shift
could only see about five
to seven babies per day.
Yes. So, there's the time
taken to monitor this data,
also time taken to collect
the data in the form
of audio accounts,
which is speaking to parents,
asking simple
follow-up questions.
There's also a lot
of subjectivity.
So, as you might have seen
in the previous slides,
there's an example of the images
that we receive
through these videos.
So, through these videos,
the nurses are
expected to assess the skin
color of the babies,
the chest movement, and this
would depend on the skill level
of the nurses itself.
Also on ambient lighting the way
the video was shot, etc.
So, factors that could
be controlled and
require of reduction in
subjectivity when it
comes to analysis.
So, this is our vision
of how we think
technology could help
us in scaling
this intervention and
reaching across to more babies.
One would be risk assessment.
So, we think that we could make
better use of
the skilled workforce
simply by doing a
preliminary assessments.
So, such that the cases that
require origin detention,
reach the assessor first.
Also, flagging
some severe danger signs,
which do not even require
a clinical assessment,
but would simply
require medical care.
So, this would reduce
response times in such a system.
Then we can also improve
on the workflow.
So, if our nurse sees
that a baby is falling
ill, typically,
we ask follow-up questions like,
"What was the feeding pattern
in the last 24 hours?"
So, we try to collect
information about
the current medical behavior and
also past history of the baby,
which we think could be automated
again to increase response times.
Also, once we prescribe
a line of treatment,
there could be more
effective ways
of sending reminders and
tracking if
the treatment is being
followed through
technological systems.
In terms of the video
assessment, simply,
also we think that there
could be data processing such
that preliminary assessments can
be done for respiratory rate,
image analysis, can be
done to see skin color,
reduced subjectivity, and shorten
the time taken to review
these 2.5 minute long videos.
Yes. So, the data that
we have right now,
so we start from the day of
enrollment in the study rate.
So, we have a lot
of baseline data.
So, we know factors about
the baby's birth like
the weight at birth,
the gestational age,
how long the baby
has spent time in
a tertiary care facility?
What kind of care did it receive
at the tertiary facility?
Then, we also have
demographic information
about what was the age
of this mother?
Is this the mother's
first pregnancy?
What kind of a household
does the baby come from?
Then, in terms of the daily
monitoring, we have videos.
So, we have
detailed analysis from
these care nurses about what
was the activity level
in the video?
Was the baby crying?
Was the baby crying loud enough?
Was there any chest indrawing?
Then, through
our vital signs monitor,
we have data about
the average heart rate,
in the 2.5 minute video,
and also the oxygen saturation.
Then, through the audio accounts,
we have details about,
in the last six to eight hours,
how often has the baby been fed?
How often has the baby
passed urine or stool?
Does the mother see
any abnormalities?
Has she seen any
convulsive movements?
Has she seen anything
on the skin of
the baby that could
potentially be problematic?
Yes. So, that's the end
of our presentation.
We do have some ideas on how
we could leverage the data.
We're excited to discuss it
in the following sessions.
>> Anyone with questions?
>> You said you were
compiling this,
how many babies has
these technology been used with?
>> We've used it with
a little over 100 babies
in Karnataka State and
Telangana State of India.
Yeah.
>> Hi. What device
are you using currently
for video monitoring?
Are you using a mobile phone?
>> Yes. For our pilot projects,
we're just using a smartphone
because that enables
us to control the quality
of video that comes in,
and also this packet of data can
be sent through
cellular networks.
So, yeah, we are using
a smartphone right now.
>> But won't mobile phones be
contaminated most of the time?
Because there was
a study a few days back,
talking about how 101 out of
105 mobile phones that they
studied was contaminated with
bacteria in health care.
>> Okay. Can you go back to
the slide with the picture?
So, this is what the product
looks like right now.
So, the smartphone is placed
on top of this stand,
which is at least
40-centimeter above the baby.
So, there's no point of time when
the baby is in contact
with the phone.
I hope that answers
your question.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> We take one more question,
and then we'll have a break one
session to discuss this further.
>> I guess you guys are
doing what sounds like
a relatively small
scale pilot right now,
but just in terms of thinking
about how you might want
this to be implemented,
who would you imagine actually
buying and having this resource,
and how do you
imagine it be used?
>> Okay. So, you
saw the products that we've
developed before which is
the hypothermia bracelet.
So, for that product,
we have used government channels
as well as private channels.
So, we see a system,
where we would use this,
we would integrate
our clinical team with
the tertiary level facilities
in district hospitals.
We would be enrolling
babies that are
discharged from these facilities.
So, we expect that the
government would work with us to
subsidize the care that
this system could offer to
these babies being discharged
from the hospital.
Also in the private cases,
even in Tier-2 and
Tier-3 cities of India.
So, remote assessment would
significantly reduce the cost,
and increase the quality of
care that is accessible.
>> So, Villant you had
one question. We'll allow.
>> I had one more
question please.
>> Okay, we can take two.
>> I think in
the interest of moving
to the break up, I'll hold it.
>> Fantastic. We'll come to you.
>> So, you mentioned
that there are audio
accounts of these.
So, are these in local languages
or they have mixed,
code mixed, or what kind
of accounts are they?
>> They are largely in
local languages because
60 percent of our used cases
are currently in rural India.
So, they would be
in local languages.
>> [inaudible].
>> Yes.
>> So, currently, you would
get them transcribed by?
>> Not transcribed, but they
would be assessed on the call.
So, we don't note down everything
that is relayed by the parents,
but we would only note down
the frequency of feeds.
We'd convert that into
as many quantitative
values as possible.
>> Okay. Is that
interactive? The-
>> Yes. It's a phone call.
>> Okay. Thank you.